- [Narrator] In this
video we're gonna talk
about balance sheets, and in
particular, balance sheets
for banks in a fractional
reserve lending system.
Now, it's not just banks
that have balance sheets.
All corporations have a balance sheet.
You can even have your own
individual balance sheet.
That is a snap shot of,
what do you have of value
and what do you owe to other people?
Now the things that you have of value,
if we're talking about a bank,
the things that the bank has of value,
those are called assets.
And that could be cash that
the bank has in it's vaults.
It might be property that the bank owns.
And the things that the bank owes
to other people are liabilities.
Liabilities.
And, this might be money that
the bank owes to someone else,
some future obligation.
Now there's this other notion of equity.
And when we're talking
about a corporation,
like a bank, equity is what's left over.
If you take your assets and
you subtract your liabilities
equity is, you could
view it as the net worth.
How much net value is
owned by the shareholders.
And to make this tangible
you can look at an analogy
to your everyday life.
If you're thinking about your
own personal balance sheet,
let's say the only asset
you owned was a car
that was worth $10,000.
$10,000 car.
So that is your asset.
And let's say that you
only have one liability.
You had to borrow $8,000 in order to buy
that $10,000 car.
So this is something that
you owed to other folks,
so that is your liability.
What would be your equity here?
What would be your net worth?
Well, if you own something worth $10,000,
if all of your assets are 10 thousand,
but you owe eight thousand,
what you have left over
that's going to be $2,000.
And so this would be your
equity, in every language,
as often times the net worth.
And so assets minus
liabilities is equal to equity.
Or, if you add liabilities
to both sides of that
you could say that assets are equal
to liabilities plus, plus equity.
And so when you see many balance sheets
it's typical to see it in two columns.
On the left hand side you have assets,
and on the right hand side you
have liabilities plus equity.
And these two things should
add up to the same amount.
So whatever assets are,
liabilities plus equity
should add up to that same amount.
So now let's use this framework
to start ourselves a bank.
And so, let's say we immediately
go and buy a building
and some equipment
worth a million dollars.
Just to even have a place to run the bank.
And so, we immediately
have assets of building,
building plus equipment, plus
equipment, of $1,000,000.
Now I just said, whatever
our total assets are,
that would be our
liabilities plus our equity.
So in this situation what
are our liabilities so far?
Remember, the balance
sheet gives us a snap shot
at any moment in time.
Well, so far I don't
owe anything to anyone.
I'll just assume that I
had that million dollars,
I didn't have to borrow from
anyone to get that million.
So I have zero dollars in liabilities.
And so what would the equity be?
Pause the video and think about that.
Well, liabilities plus equity
needs to be $1,000,000.
If liabilities is zero, then
our equity is $1,000,000.
So if I'm the owner of
the bank, this tell me
that the value of what
I own is $1,000,000.
But as we know, banks don't
exist just to be a building.
They take deposits from people
and then they make loans to people.
So let's say someone's
walkin' down the street
and they see our bank and say,
Hey, that looks like a good
place to deposit their money.
It looks like a safe place,
maybe they'll get some interest on it.
And so they come and they give
a million dollar cash deposit.
They have a suitcase with a
million dollars of cash in it.
So how would that be reflected
on this balance sheet?
Well, it would actually get
categorized as reserves.
Reserves you can view as
the federal reserve notes,
the cash, that it has on hand.
It could be money that's in it's vault.
It could be an account that
it has with the central bank,
although that gets a little
bit more sophisticated.
But you can visualize it as it's cash.
One way to simplify it.
And so in this situation your reserves
are now going to be $1,000,000.
Where did that come from?
It came from that suitcase of
cash that that person gave.
Now, what happens on the right hand side
of this balance sheet?
They didn't just give us the money.
At some future point in
time they might withdraw
some or all of that money.
Our liabilities now,
so we now have a demand deposit.
Let me write it this way.
Demand deposit for $1,000,000.
And this is a good time
to pause this video
and really understand this
because this is essential
for understanding banks,
is that yes, we got that cash,
but it's offset by a liability.
Because at some point in the future
we have to give that million dollars back
to that person who made that deposit.
And they can come on demand.
Now you might be saying,
"All right this is all nice,
"but how am I, as a bank,
going to make money?"
And the main way that banks make money
is by making loans.
But how do they loan out
the money if all of this
is on demand deposit?
Well, in a fractional reserve system
you don't have to keep all
of your demand deposits
on hand as reserves.
You can actually lend
out a good chunk of it.
And it's dictated by what the
required reserve ratios are.
So let's say in the country we're in,
or the jurisdiction we're in,
the required reserve ratio,
so required reserve ratio,
is 10% of demand deposits.
That means that we can, whatever
our demand deposits are,
we have to keep 10% of that in reserves,
and then the excess
reserves we can loan out.
And so I can now group my reserves.
Instead of saying a million
dollars of just total reserves,
I could sub-categorize
it as required reserves,
required reserves, and excess reserves.
Now, what do you think are
going to be the required
and excess reserves in this scenario?
Pause this video and figure it out.
Well, required and access
are going to add up
to my total million dollars of reserves.
The required reserves are
10% of my demand deposits.
So I have to keep 10%
of this million dollars,
which is $100,000, and then the rest
is excess reserves of $900,000.
And so this model is based on
the idea that statistically,
especially if these demand deposits
are coming from many different people,
it's unlikely that more
than 10% will be withdrawn
at any moment in time.
And we talk about runs on banks
where this tends to break down.
And so banks will then
lend out this other 90%
of the demand deposits, or up
to 90% of the demand deposits,
and they lend them out
to people they think
are likely to pay the money with interest.
And that interest is how
banks make the money.
And so this bank could say,
Hey I have 900 thousand
of excess reserves, which
I can use to make loans
to other people.
And so let's say a
bunch of people come by,
and they have some good ideas,
and we think that they're
going to pay us back.
So what we do is, we can
take those excess reserves,
up to $900,000 of them,
and instead of having
this excess reserves we
can put 'em out as loans.
So we can make loans of $900,000.
Now one thing that might
be counterintuitive
to some of you, is say,
wait I'm used to a loan
being something like a liability.
Here we just said we owed people money,
and so that was an
obligation to other people.
Why is it an asset here?
Well, it depends if you are the lender
or your the person borrowing the money.
Here, as the bank, we're the lender.
The loan is an asset
because someone is going
to pay us money back in the future.
This has value.
If we owed money to someone else,
well then that would be a liability.
And so, now notice here, the whole time
that we were doing this,
the assets were equal
to the liabilities plus equity.
Assets right now are $2,000,000.
One million, plus 100
thousand, plus 900 thousand.
And our liabilities plus
equity are $2,000,000.
One million in liabilities,
one million in equity.